Imagine that this is the beginning of the
last thing you’ll ever see, an empty landscape
with thin lines scratched across it.
But those lines suddenly sharpen and gather
into a dense mass that spreads from the crown
that sits atop a giant, studded with greens
and yellows.
A giant that is in search of one thing: food.
And then imagine, that you are that food.
Tiny in the face of this alien whose body
is designed to take you in and break you down.
And as it retracts, pulling away from the
scenery, you disappear with it.
We're letting magnification and music do
a lot of the heavy lifting when it comes to
setting the scene.
Up close, this animal is upsetting, its movements
slow until they are sudden, peaceful until
they are predatory.
But from further away, things are a little
different.
It still looks strange, but it seems less
overwhelming than before.
It seems just kind of chill, even as this
other large organism brushes by.
The animal we’ve been focused on belongs
to the genus Collotheca, making it one of
our favorite types of animals: a rotifer.
And we’ve happened upon many rotifer mishaps
and adventures in the microcosmos before.
They’re always being bullied or eaten or caught
up in some tragic tale of their own making.
But in the case of the Collotheca, their biggest
bullies might be themselves.
Because these organisms love to eat, even
if that means eating each other.
Collotheca are put in an awkward position
when it comes to seeking out food because
they can’t easily hunt it down.
Most Collotheca species are sessile, which
means they don’t really swim around.
Instead, they spend most of their lives stuck,
attaching themselves to whatever is in their
vicinity and seems like it might be a good
home, like the ones you see here.
And while they’re there, the Collotheca
surround themselves in a gelatinous tube,
giving them a sort of squishy sleeping bag they
can retract into when something disturbs them.
And it turns out, it’s very easy to disturb
them.
Those long threads we saw at the beginning
of the video aren’t just decoration.
They are there to help the rotifer sense
the world around them, both so they can recognize
danger and so that they can find food.
The hairs are called cilia, and we’ve seen
them on other rotifers before.
In fact, they’re a defining feature, part
of the inspiration for the name “rotifer,”
which translates to “wheel bearer”.
It’s the fast spinning whirling motion of
the cilia that gives the head of the rotifer
its wheel-y appearance.
But while the cilia are notable on all rotifer,
they are particularly long and noticeable
on the Collotheca.
And they also seem to be extremely sensitive.
James, our master of microscopes, has found
that if he’s recording Collotheca, he has
to be extra careful to not walk around the
microscope.
If he does walk, the vibrations in his steps
reach the Collotheca and drive them to retract
into their gelatinous safety vest.
Like other rotifers, Collotheca appear to
be able to use their cilia to create currents
that draw food into their mouths.
Whether it’s algae or some other kind of
single-celled organism, or even a tiny crustacean
like a water flea, the Collotheca probably
doesn’t care as long as it gets fed.
It uses its enormous mouth to close in on
whatever it’s eating, wrapping it up in
the bony jaw called the trophi, and then swallowing
its prey in a jerky motion.
Based on what James has observed, he’s been
starting to suspect something kind of funny
about how Collotheca get their food because
sometimes, you’ll see smaller organisms
just swim right into their mouths.
So James thinks they may be getting a little
extra help, that when the Collotheca retracts
into itself, it’s actually pushing a little bit of
the stuff in its stomach into its giant mouth.
And in that regurgitated mass are nutrients
that could be attracting single-celled organisms
toward the rotifer.
Now we’re not sure if that’s what
happening—that the rotifer is puking into
own mouth to lure in more food.
But if it is true, it's still not the weirdest
way that Collotheca gets a meal.
That would probably be the cannibalism.
But not just any form of cannibalism will
do for the Collotheca.
It is specifically, a baby cannibal, fully
willing to eat its own child.
Cannibalism is a striking behavior for Collotheca,
but not necessarily a surprising one.
In the same study where this behavior was
documented, another non-Collotheca rotifer
was observed engaging in sexual cannibalism,
where the female rotifer would eat the male
rotifer after mating was completed.
That behavior is not unheard of in the animal
kingdom, where insects and spiders turn their
last mate into their next meal.
It’s not clear if Collotheca do the same
thing to their male counterparts.
In fact, for a long time, it wasn’t even
clear that they had male counterparts.
We’ve known about Collotheca for more than
a century, but the first male Collotheca wasn’t
observed until 1986.
And it turns out that male Collotheca were
generally smaller, and most importantly, their
lifespans were super short—on the order
of 20 hours.
It is as if they were born just to breed
and then die soon after.
But we're getting away from our original
topic: the cannibalism.
The captions from the paper documenting this
tell the story quite succinctly.
From Panel A: “female neonate emerging from
gelatinous tube.”
From Panels B-D: “adult female ingesting
female neonate.”
It’s simple, poignant, and tragic for the
female neonate.
It’s also completely unclear to us how common
this behavior is, and why the rotifer mother
might engage in it.
It does not seem to be a great way to
pass on your genes.
Perhaps it was just in need of a nutritious
snack, perhaps it was a mistake.
Perhaps, in the microcosmos, rotifers can't
be choosers.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you especially to these people here
on the screen right now, they are our patrons
on Patreon.
They make it possible for us to continue to
explore this bizarre and beautiful world,
and to make observations that we can't yet
confirm but hopefully some day we will be
able to.
Like that rotifers, maybe, puke in their own
mouths to attract food.
If you like what we do here you can go to
Patreon.com/JournytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram or TikTok.
And if you want to see more from us here, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.